and I guess some of this too is one just
the philosophy of doing it the second is
actual execution right now and I love
that you said hey look call your senator
I'll come negotiate it with it yeah
absolutely it is their merit to the idea
of let's go get five or ten business
leaders who have done these deals over
and over and over again and say look
Treasury we're gonna come in and you
know you're not gonna charge you
anything but we're gonna help you
negotiate fair deals or advantageous
deals or do you start to get into a
situation where it's just too hard to do
something like that
I mean everything's hard right now right
so there's going to be a challenge but
you know in reading as much as I could
of the law they they created an
oversight committee already right and so
the goal would be not to just have
politicians on that Oversight Committee
right because they're gonna be
influenced they have their own dogmas
and they basically represent two parties
and so you want to get some independent
names on there again I'll volunteer for
the oversight to they said all the
contracts had to be transparent and
published right so everybody's going to
see them you know and so you don't want
to look stupid and you don't want the
entire country just to think we just
gave all this money away our hard-earned
taxpayer money because somebody was just
doing somebody a favor or somebody
didn't have the skill set in order to do
a negotiation and so yeah I mean we want
to have transparency and it's okay on
this Oversight Committee to say to have
people in there who are going to call
them out because the minute that first
one hits if it isn't well done rip them
to shreds right that's our job you know
as concerned citizens why wouldn't we
yeah you know if it's not a deal we feel
is a good deal for the United States of
America of course you want to say
something yeah and my whole thing too is
what why would you not want to have
people who have experienced doing this
stuff right that's no brainer you know
what if the company doesn't want it
bye-bye
go get your money somewhere else well if
the company is fighting back against
who's on the Oversight Committee that
probably means that they did a good job
selecting who's on the committee so
we've seen companies obviously go and
look for the bailout money now what
we're starting to see is yesterday we
saw a group of governor's come out and
say look we need 500 billion dollars to
fill out state local governments you see
things like the MTA in New York cities
saying hey wait a second right or shuts
down ninety percent we might not be able
to pay our bonds kind of you're getting
outside of
just pure capitalism and private and
public companies into these other things
how do you think about bailouts or
relief or help for those types of
organizations I mean yeah do it
otherwise you creates a cascading effect
that could be far worse I mean look what
do they call it mm t the monetary yeah I
forget what the acronym stands for but
um where you just keep on you know
pretty money and then you see what
happens we're gonna find out right this
is a real-world experiment but you know
the other side of the coin is you know
what happens if you don't you know if
all these companies you know all these
organizations can't pay their bills you
know like the MTA you know like the you
know transportation organizations in
every city right the local governments
in every city are facing the same
problems if we don't pay it we know
what'll happen so we've got to try it so
yeah I'm not opposed to it but you got
to make sure there's no fluff in there
right and you've got to make sure that
it's being run as efficiently as
possible and then I get look I'm a
libertarian at heart and the idea of
government being efficient is an
oxymoron but you know we don't have a
lot of options we just have to try to
have some good oversight yeah are you
then worried I generally agree that
they're gonna have to do it right
they're in a lose-lose situation they
got to do it do you get worried about
inflation on the other side of this
where it could get out of hand because
they've got him they're just printing
before it was just like okay you know
when we do all these bailouts in 2009
2010 inflation is gonna be rampant and
it wasn't you know and then we've had
you know other scenarios where the
interest rates go down to zero or
negative interest in other countries and
inflation hasn't been rampant it's been
you know deflation is born more of a
risk than inflation so you know every
economist will give you a different
answer I don't have an answer um but
we'll find out won't we and and we'll
know for the future because this is you
know a great experiment for future
generations now hopefully they're not
going to go through the same [ __ ] we're
going through but at the same time we'll
learn about monetary policy will learn
about fiscal policy will learn about the
impact of interest rates um and we'll go
from there
yeah make sense one of the things that
I've been thinking a lot through is this
balance between the health crisis and
economic crisis and I think a lot of
people look at it black and white they
say hey they're you yes
stop the health Christ so you stop that
how mama crisis you just can't make that
decision and so how do you think through
on a framework basis like you got to
address both of them it's like what are
some of those solutions that we can move
towards what kind of the way I'm looking
at it I actually see the health crisis
is being short-term right but the the
economic crisis is being potentially
much longer-term but you can't you
you've got to deal with both of them
right and so all the things we've been
talking about in terms of the economic
issues yeah you have to address that
we're gonna have to create jobs you know
we're gonna have to have tracers on that
do you know higher half a million a
million people that just go trace all
these illnesses and see where they trace
back to if only to create work right
we're gonna have to do things like
AmeriCorps is a great AmeriCorps is a
great program that has a small budget
give them a huge or budget because we're
gonna have to create jobs and that's
gonna be a long-term issue that we
address hopefully like in 2009-2010 when
we start to come out of it relatively
quickly and and you know a couple years
hopefully but on the health side I'm
really optimistic that we'll have a
vaccine you know in trial shortly and
out of trial within a year and we'll
have therapies within months but even
those therapies are going to take time
to build confidence and I just think you
know coming out of this people are going
to have to make the decisions make their
own decisions on what they do next and
that will define where we go from here
and that's just going to take agility
you know and that you know that's going
to be the operative word for America 2.0
being resilient being able to bounce
back and be and hash out those two
things and you know but agility is gonna
be word number one yeah it's really
interesting too because I think that the
way we kind of went into quarantine and
lockdown really drove the point home
right as I hey get your asses at home
stay at home we gotta crush the curve
all the things that we saw on social
media et cetera the flip side of this is
now how do we come out of it right I
think that actually the way you come out
of the quarantine has a lot of impact on
the psychology do people go spend will
they go to that movie theater really do
this stuff any thoughts on just like yes
actually dunk
yeah the answer is no right because it's
going to be a process there is no one
thing
there is no life switch like everybody
saying it will be a process where you'll
build trust and you have to know that
going into the deals that you do so as
part of a bailout for an airline if the
government stands across all the
airlines of billion dollars a year for
airline seats for commercial travel
let's prepay that billion dollars and
let's work out a deal with Airlines to
say okay you know the first travelers on
your plane or your planes are going to
be government employees and here's the
requirements that we're gonna set in
place for your planes in terms of
sanitization sterilization whatever the
CDC etc requires and we'll do that and
you know we'll make sure that they're
okay and that'll start to build
confidence we'll work with sports teams
and arenas we'll put together programs
where we won't have an arena full but
we'll start playing the game so we can
only see groups of people together in an
area that won't end up getting sick
again that goes back to the agility
we're gonna have to just test things out
and that's what'll build confidence and
of course there's gonna be kids that you
know feel they're invincible and they're
gonna go out and do whatever anyways so
gonna be back in the beach they're gonna
be back in the pools they're gonna be
back party and no matter what and then
we'll see an increased incidence in
infants of Kovac right and we'll learn
our lesson but it's going to be an
ongoing process but what I do think the
government needs to do is very clearly
set standards on cleanliness and
presentation right and information so
that if you're walking into if you're
going to the park and there's a park
bench and you want to bring your grandma
there you want to see a seal of approval
that says this is the last time this
bench was sanitized right it may be an
app where you just pointed out it may be
AR where it shows whatever it may be
they're gonna have to be things that the
government sets the standards that our
confidence builders for us just like
when we went back after 9/11 and we had
the TSA there and the lines were long
and you knew was a pain in the ass and
you knew you could just run to the gate
anymore but that helped give us
confidence
we'll need the same type of standards
for from the CDC so that we ran whoever
maybe so that we know that the right
things are being done because we can see
the stickers everywhere and when that
starts to happen and people don't get
sick
then you'll start to see an acceleration
of people coming out and the new
abnormal if you will